hello ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much for sticking with us here at
gamespot during our live coverage of e3
2014 I'm your host Chris waters and
right now we've got zombies monsters
robots in that order possibly one on top
of the other I don't know how exactly
it's gonna play out but Matt sonam here
is here from n mass entertainment and I
is gonna show me what it's all about
Matt welcome to the stage thank you glad
to have you on here can you can you flex
your zombies monsters robots t-shirt
there check nice nice uh we've got the
laptop here we got a game set up because
zombies monsters robots is in a closed
beta right now he's got people r Aaron
to play with you yeah we have we have a
small audience playing the game right
now helping to test but next week you're
going into closed beta 2 we're ramping
up we're going to fight a whole bunch
more people into the game and it's a
multiplayer-focused game so that just
means more fun more action excellent all
right well let's speaking of let's get
into it and while we do set us up the
wood what mode this is this is like a
horde mode kind of thing yeah we're
jumping into a mode called kill
everything and it's a survival bass boat
like a horde mode as you said kill
everything yes all right that's really
on the nose all right yeah we don't pull
any punches it's no no qualms about it
oh and with the name like zombies
monsters robots right you're gonna kill
everything so we had like zombie dogs
and in this particular map was which is
called mercy killing it takes place in a
hospital so you're killing like zombie
nurses and janitorial staff really the
works and it culminates in a zombie
janitorial set of those sinister of us
take that orderly and it culminates in a
crazy boss fight with a sea monster
because hey why not right sure it's
right there in the title gotta put it in
there kill everything is our tagline all
right so I'm going to join a game in
progress or not in progress we're gonna
start it up in a moment cool and if that
headsets give you a little trouble you
can just squeeze it together the metal
is uh is malleable you can pop it off
and pinching it if you want no problem
my head and while you finagle with it a
little bit i'll remind you folks that
we're taking questions for all of your
for all of our live stage demos here you
just send them in to us via twitter
using the hashtag gamespot III you can
send them to me personally at CT waters
oh
you can join the game spa chat room and
put your questions than there will try
to take a look it's been awesome having
you guys ask questions this whole time
so you gotta 94 zombies monsters robots
send them our way so Matt we're gonna
hop in here and you got a bit of a
character select screen or we just seen
your customized carriage this is the
lobby and yeah there's a bunch of
characters in the game as you can see
and they're all customized with various
geared equipment you can customize the
look and feel of your character of
course as well as earn and unlock guns
in the game to your liking and customize
various loadouts up to 4 loadouts that
may suit different scenarios the game it
has co-opted based modes but also pvp as
well so you might have a low note that's
tailored to competitive play whereas
another low don't may be more geared to
cooperative play taking down zombies
depending on the enemy type of
essentially or the map that you're gonna
play right on so are you playing as dr.
guy Rambo fan metal gear solid dude or a
lady cambo iron the back oh you're in
the back yeah tank top yeah tank top
McGee awesome that's me alright so this
is 5 player co-op horde mode yes but
kill everything mode when he's a proper
nomenclature here but some modes some
maps support up to 8 players and that's
when the action gets really frantic and
crazy okay so that's a that's a mode and
maps sort of designee yes there's even
like campaign modes in the game where
you play through like a little bit of a
standalone story uh-huh depending on the
difficulty they usually take about an
hour to complete and they tell a little
bit of a story and their linear and
those support up to 8 players which is
crazy like it's hordes of zombies and
crazy robots and all sorts of different
enemy types but with eight players on
screen it just gets it gets out of
control yeah so it seems like definitely
guys really leaning into sort of the a
lot of quantity a lot of over-the-top
sort of action yeah it we chose the name
is all responses robots just for that
very reason you know cuz it is help oh
wow look at this top the table up a
little bit yeah give you a little more
you guys are well equipped for this oh
yeah so you can see here my character
its third base shooter talk about their
person shooter you'll notice if you look
at me reload it has the active reload
system which you may be
Miller with from two years ago yeah
that's a good mechanic yeah so even when
you're reloading its action packed these
guys just handily handedly cleared out
the first wave well wait the action will
ramp up in subsequent waves of course
and then it culminates in this final
boss fight as I said with a sea monster
which we've we've called the Reaper fish
the repo fish in this specific gameplay
mode you cannot take cover but in PvP
the the gameplay is very much like stop
and pop like Gears of War style and
you'll notice here see these these
zombies coming in over these barricades
yeah once they destroy them a little bit
the team can work together to repair
them which will impede the progress of
zombies and subsequent waves yes so
you've got good you know fortification
thing going do you have now that sort of
a defensive barricade do you have any
offensive assets in terms yes you do in
each map there are environmental traps
that the team can work together to
activate you'll notice as I barricade
windows and doors and as I kill zombies
I'm accruing points at the top of the
screen those points can be spent on
weapon pick up scattered throughout the
map and to activate those environmental
traps that I mentioned you'll notice
that a player on my team just picked up
a bomb and that clears the wave that
kills all the enemies on screen like
bombs do yeah and there's various
pickups of that variety in the game
where you can like pick up a pickup or
pick up a drop that will give everybody
maximum ammo here you'll notice I'm
repairing the door here or the window
rather and you're irresponsible of you
I'm sorry very responsible of you and as
you do if two players prepare it
together it's meets up the progress of
course so this you know you've sort of
name dropped a few other games in your
description of the mechanics and those
are good reference points certainly to
help players understand what you guys
are you know we're inspiration fly at
but so how do you with zombies monsters
robots what do you where you guys
carving out your niche in terms of like
the player experience when people come
to your game what do you want them what
kind of experiences you want them to
have so the game is very much a number
of games like it's a mash-up and there's
a ton of stuff I think what really makes
zombies monsters robots or TMR as we
call it stand out is just the sheer
variety of different game modes on
display as I mentioned we have PvP but
we also have you
boats like we have a moat upcoming mode
called mercs vs monsters that puts
players in it's a pvp competitive mode
okay puts players in control of the
monsters themselves has a different
ability I talking about language yeah
and then we have like another
cooperative mode where it's called
threshold defense and players will work
together to prevent enemies that they're
proceeding towards a portal at the back
and you have to stop them from
progressing to that point so players can
set up turrets on the map it's very much
like a tower defense down mode and
players can set up turrets and other
traps of in the environment to impede
the progress of zombies and prevent them
from escaping through this portal and
that modes unique in the sense that
you're not just fighting zombies but
also like mercenaries been shoot back in
you as well so it's a mash-up of all the
different enemy types in the game this
current mode is just zombies but there's
other way play survival modes where you
fight mercs that shoot back at you with
rocket launchers grenades and in another
weaponry I gotta say Matt I haven't
heard a lot of talk about robots so far
yes so there is an upcoming mode as well
called mech team match our team
deathmatch and that puts players and
controls of mex as well so you'll be
flying around boosting around as well
and fighting other players equipped in
mech suits when you say flying around is
that sort of like a like I mean are you
talking like full-on like armored core
condom ecsta you can rust around and
okay on a limiter yes alright okay Oh
zombie nurse yeah you've never stood a
chance so here you see you like a little
zombie dog and then there's just a wide
variety of different enemy types this is
just kind of like a sample have you guys
are definitely you know metals more like
a zombie hyena man that thing is nasty
alright how else sort of you know you
guys have a certain definitely a certain
sense of humor going here with the game
you guys definitely have a certain sense
of humor going with the game yeah how
goofy are you getting like where you
draw the line oh like you know lovey
janitorial staff is one thing but you're
not you know we
really I don't know that there is a live
there okay here's the duct tape coming
out in the future that has dinosaurs and
they have missiles strapped to their
backs so like I don't know the sky's the
limit pretty much ah that's fantastic
tell me that the dinosaurs will be
playable Matt oh I'll be labeled
auditory oh no plans as of yet but that
would be fantastic hey listen you know
development doesn't stop when the game
comes out do want to hear somethin i
wanta c playable dinosaurs especially in
the case of zombies monsters robots we
have a monthly update schedule
post-release know we got closed beta to
launch it next week and then we have a
big update planned in early July and
then every month after that we're going
to introduce new weapons new maps and
even new gameplay modes to the game and
so I you know with monthly updates talk
to me about the like pricing structure
for zombies monsters robots so every
weapon in the game currently can be
unlocked through gameplay okay and it's
free to play it's totally free to play
yes and you so you can earn these things
called that you were in bullets by
completing maps and you can exchange
those in a shooting gallery for new
weaponry or you can just purchase
weapons if you don't want to wait it out
and you can purchase this with them
directly as well with with money or
there's a weapons that can also be
purchased with in-game currency as well
and you can also purchase things like
turrets and stuff that can help you out
on maps such as this as well so those
will be expendable resources toward the
tour assumable yes zoomable that's the
word I was looking for thank you yeah
and what about like character in terms
of character customization you know
obviously the loadouts are a big part of
it I are what about outfits there's lots
of zany outfits as well that players can
purchase we're going to be adding those
over time as well right now the web the
the outfits that are currently available
are kind of reeled in there not Tuesday
knee but there are some that are coming
back I think the humor and style of the
game alright well that certainly some
some wacky action here and with you guys
you're different your outfits your
zombies your mobsters your robots the
whole shebang yeah tell folks how they
can get into the closed beta to you guys
are launching next week sure so we'll be
giving away teams through game gamespot
actually so people stay tuned to
gamespot com next week they'll be able
to
secure themself a key for the closed
beta yes a little bit of promotion there
but if you want to sign up for the beta
today it for a chance to get in we're
sending invites constantly you can go to
ww plays EMR calm and sign up there for
a chance to be eligible to play in the
beta as well very cool Matt thank you so
much for coming on thank you sure enough
some zmr that one